[Music]
I'm Jake one of 40 finalists competing
for the hundred thousand dollar teal
camp
it all comes down to a two-minute pitch
in one life-changing decision to drop
out of school and pursue our dreams this
is team technorati
[Music]
if you're one of the three million
people who watched me ask Kate Upton to
my prom on YouTube then you already know
I'm not exactly shy but in this
competition the lightning round is so
crucial that we all needed coaching to
make our pitches as compelling as
possible the point of this game is about
being in the moment when you have your
lightning round you want to be sending
your message with intention like I'm a
wall and then you turn around and send
it to Lucy whoa no you said the wood
you're gonna share two truths about
yourself and a lie but in any order that
you want hi I'm Andrew I have been
chased by a police helicopter I like to
watch B movies I have seen the ghost of
Elvis Presley my dad is 62 and my mom is
five - they're like this what we've been
working on is this app called finish
it's the to do this for procrastinators
it works because we split your stuff
into short mid and long term time frames
you asked have just based on the due
date and we slide it up over time we did
50,000 downloads in the first 48 hours
which was just super freakin crazy
for the two-minute pitch tomorrow I've
been trying to figure out how nervous I
should be
[Music]
no I don't have a problem dude it means
the teal finding this bachelors of this
year yeah if you make eye contact with
someone that means you're dead
I have been onstage before for everybody
it's a lot scary the work that I've been
doing on cancer it's probably the
biggest achievement I've done so far q16
is gonna hear cancer that's pretty
incredible it's just awe-inspiring I'm
using automated high-throughput drug
screening to test hundreds even
thousands of small molecules from drug
candidates that could prevent cancer
this is called the hula loop we wanted
to see how they would work as teams and
how they treated each other because
again that's a huge part of the
fellowship is for not to be a
competitive situation but we want people
to work together and support each other
many people could really take advantage
of their youth by trying out new things
even if like some people might put you
down by saying you're too young or you
should go to college first I think the
interesting thing about the fellowship
is you're surrounded by people that act
very adult-like
but at the same time these are people
that can't buy alcohol
so now we're all warmed up but as time
runs out on the lightning pitches things
are getting hotter in here subscribe to
the wire channel for the next episode of
teen Technorati
[Music]